there is a 19 year old girl Mary Phelps
Jacob setting up to go to a debutante
ball and she is like ah I got this
beautiful silk dress and I have to put
this dumb piece of on stupid corset
with whale bone inserts us so goddamn
dumb alright I'm I'm I'm out I'm out
I can't take this Marie
[Music]
Marie get me two handkerchiefs some silk
cording ribbons and a sewing kit she
sews together two handkerchiefs onto
herself and goes to a ball all the girls
are like what is going on with you girl
you look better than you have ever
looked and she says yeah I just made
this awesome handkerchiefs the girls go
crazy
she's like my boobles are free to roam
and they all say I want one I want one I
want one all right whatever I'll make
you some mom make you my new thing
whatever it was some handkerchiefs then
she gets a letter in the mail from
someone she's never met saying hey I'll
give you a dollar to make me a bra and
then she realizes oh this could be a
business so she goes to the Patent
Office
and she said hey I've made this thing
it's a brassiere the Patent Office guy
was like everyone's had boobs for
goddamn forever I understand that you
think you made something but you didn't
and she said no I did the last piece of
patent flattens your tits into nothing
but one boob do you want one boob and
he's like I don't I can't even I don't
even know if I can answer this no you
want to in boobs they separate and lift
give me the patent for the backless
brassiere and he says yeah okay all
right I've never seen that I will give
you a patent slam he gives her a patent
oh god I'm I'm not gonna throw up but I
am I'm pretty
gonzo Bonzo so she opens the fashion
form brassiere company meanwhile she
marries this guy Harry Crosby and Harry
says hey babe because you're gonna be my
wife Crosby I feel like you should have
a cname so it's like C Crosby I would
really like it if you change your name
to clitoris
it's fing true and she says what no I'm
not gonna change my name to clitoris
he's like no it's with a Y still I'm
sorry I Love You Man
honey but not even with a why will I
name myself clitoris
what about caress that's better than
clitoris certainly he says to her hey
caress correct she's now caressed you're
kind of bored with the bra business and
it's not taking off I'm kind of rich
while you just let it go she says all
right fine she sells her patent to the
Warner Brothers corset company for
fifteen hundred dollars she's like I'm
out I'm good
had fun so wait I have to fast-forward I
also have to pee which one you're under
first no I have to pee okay well then
pee I'm gonna in 1929 the bra took hold
everyone bought bras the corset was dead
the Warner Brothers corset company makes
15 million dollars off of her patent
alone it's a lot of titties I did here's
the theme that Mary Phelps Jacob she
never gives she was like oh I'm okay I
sold the patent not gonna dwell on it
I'm gonna open a publishing company that
publishes every modern writer known to
man
Hemingway James Joyce Henry Miller Edgar
Allan Poe there's so many more someone
look it up on an iPhone you'll see then
was writing pornography for money and
she was great at it and at the end of
her life someone asked her about like
hey you invented something and she said
yeah
yeah my invention it wouldn't take the
place and history of something like the
steamboat but yeah I invented the bra
the bra is kind of a big deal no one
gives a about a steamboat do you
know anyone who doesn't have a bra
[Music]
okay so the story we start in 1915 yes
in Chicago right and Bessie Coleman
she's 23 years old she's a young thing
she's a manicurist in Chicago and she is
the best hands down the best so like
she's doing the nails of the upper crust
elite black people in Chicago and I was
like people are like hey girl hey do my
nails girl and she's like oh my girl I
got you and they're like girl while
she's there she's reading the Chicago
Defender which is a black-owned
newspaper
she's reading about world one and what's
happening so she's like yo one day I
hope I get to be like a
pilot people at the nail shop there
people are like girl you Wilin out and
she's like no I'm gonna be a
pilot relax and she says to herself like
she's like self I'm not done I know that
I have to like train and go to school
become a pilot
so she's applying to aviation schools
and she's being rejected left and right
because of nothing besides the fact that
she's a black woman she's black and
Cherokee if this was a drink of haterade
their glass was full and they were like
hey that was them and she's like you
each and every one of you and she's
like fine like whatever like you said no
but I'm gonna keep saving my money and
so then she meets Robert as a bird and
he is the owner turns out to be other
than the Chicago Defender he's like a
girl and she's like I love your paper
your paper inspired me to even want to
be a pilot or I really want to
fly however having trouble getting into
aviation school in America America is
not having me because I'm black and I'm
a woman yeah excuse me and so Roberts
like yo you're wiling out if you think
you're gonna be a pilot in America right
now because it's not gonna happen and he
was like my advice to you would be to go
to Europe go to France you have a better
chance there and he was like if you go
there I don't also sell some papers
talking about you in my paper if you go
and really do this I will not only pay
for you to get to France bitch I will
pay for your entire school
boom so she was like fantastical so so
she took him up on his offer and she
applied and got accepted to the most
elite French school for aviation this is
like hi Lammy bitch I met Kaduna to cut
ROI Aviation was a scary thing back in
the day planes were like girl we don't
have seatbelts girl we don't have seeds
go we don't have leather and we don't
have cup holders so Betsy was learning
how to fly in France people are flying
with the assumption that they would be
okay but no security there we were safe
oh no what
no security they would be safe they were
like my legs is out of the bottom
Flintstone style they're like ma'am
ma'am ma'am cuz a lot of people die in
France
and then they was dead but so she's
watching people die she stressed out but
she gets her international piloting
license in seven months which by the way
I will say for her she was the first
female American to get this and it's
extra explosive because she was black
boom
[Music]
story begins in the year 1963 Gloria
Steinem was a graduate of Smith College
very smart she's 28 years old and she's
a journalist and show Magazine was like
hey Gloria we have a story for you we
want you to go undercover at one of Hugh
Hefner's Playboy Clubs and Playboy Clubs
were advertising themselves at the time
as like being in a real live version of
Playboy so you would have like beautiful
women everywhere and drinks and food and
dude stuff yeah boobies and vaginas and
Gloria was like I don't think this is
what I want I want people to take me
seriously and her editor was like I
think this could be your chance to call
Hugh Hefner out on his dog damn
and she was like you're right I'm in
let's do it
uh what was I talking about so she says
yes to the thing to the assignment and
so she goes to the audition which is at
a Playboy Club so she's this alias she's
created for herself which is Murray
Katheryn Oaks and the woman that she
goes up to says take off your coat let
me see your body Gloria was like okay
and like took her coat off the woman was
like you look a little old for 24 but
your body's great come back on Saturday
for a fitting and so Gloria comes back a
couple days later she sees this woman
named Cheryl E she's like I'm the bunny
mother so she goes and she gets sighs
she puts on this leotard and she's like
this fits no like no it doesn't and they
keep going in and in and Gloria is like
I think I saw an ice cube just assaulted
you got a cyst so the bunny mother
Cheryl E is explaining to the bunnies
there's all these things that they can
take your money away for like if your
ears are on crooked that's a demerit
your bunny tail is dirty
that's demerits if you're not smiling
enough that's a bunch of demerits they
also give her this bunny manual which is
a list of
all the rules that you have to follow in
the bunny manual it says you're not
allowed to date any customers but then
they were told unless they hold the
special key these special key members
were allowed to do whatever they want
oh uh duh anyway so they're like great
you're all set you're gonna start work
soon we just need you to complete your
physical and Gloria's like what do you
mean I'm gonna be a waitress oh we just
need you to complete a physical with
this doctor and then you'll be fine to
start desk girls yeah that's just gross
so just cuz the doctor she sits on the
table and she sees their stirrups and
the doctor walks in and the first thing
he says tourists so you want to be a
bunny which is alarming as a doctor he
exams her which to a woman means you
know she's a PAP patch you ever heard
one it's not a bagel Derek it's a so she
finishes the exam and she goes the next
day to train for this job that's a fancy
word for you're gonna work and not get
paid any money she's training as a table
bunny and they teach her that she just
has to follow the other bunny servers
around and so she's going around asking
people Ike hello I'm bunny Murray
what can I get for you and they would
say things like yeah girl let me see
your titties open it up which is
she's working all these shifts
and she's like in her journal she's
writing all these in Justices they're
like working these long hours they're
not making any money on top of that it's
basically a prostitution ring and after
working in the Playboy Clubs for four
weeks Gloria was like this I have
enough in my journal I'm gonna publish
this I'm out it's just all this
stupid sexist dumb ass she just
wanted to get the and so she quit
and so Gloria writes an expose on these
playboy clubs
she's like these women were like not
making as much money as they were told
they were gonna make
it's insane hours they're being grabbed
all the time they're treated like
prostitutes they're basically being used
as a tool for the male sexual revolution
but the women themselves don't get to
own their sexuality and that's shitty
and so they publicist just they
publishes they publish they publish they
publish the story in the magazine so the
world reads this article and to is very
tiny credit Hugh Hefner says wow yeah
maybe they won't have to go to these
physical exams anymore and you know what
I'm gonna stop making them have to give
so much of their money to us if they
make a mistake which is like a really
cool thing that Hugh Hefner did but also
not as cool as just like always treating
them that way
this article made Gloria Steinem a
household name and she went on to be
this huge feminist icon it's tough but I
swear to God if it weren't for Gloria
Steinem I wouldn't be able to be on TV
it's very hard to be a woman that's like
I love sports I mean you have stuck to
your guns ever since you started and
that is what you cried I'm sorry can I
get somebody else to do do this
[Laughter]
you